from the northern Atacama Desert of
Chile the European Southern Observatory
or esol observes outer space
but observing what happens on our own
planet is just as important
the eu's Earth monitoring tool is called
Copernicus a state-of-the-art satellite
data system
now thanks to a groundbreaking agreement
with the University of Chile the EU will
provide full free and open access to all
its Copernicus data to Latin America and
the Caribbean
Copernicus can detect the existence of
aerosols that deplete the ozone layer
the melting of the ice caps
monitor the quality and levels of our
oceans gather data to facilitate
alternative green energy sources and
information to warn in advance of
desertification and deforestation
number of areas actually only your
imaginations sets the borders
and it's really important for this
information to travel into knowledge to
travel into action in order to fight
climate change
EU vice president vestigar is a leading
Danish politician and former interior
minister with a long history of fighting
to reduce global warming
she was in fact the inspiration for the
Netflix Blockbuster Borgen a Danish
series about the political concessions
and issues of our times including
climate change
vestigar points out that forest fires
are one of the side effects of climate
change the Copernicus system was used
last month here to assist Chilean and EU
firefighters in mapping the trajectory
of aggressive wildfires
the EU will facilitate its Earth
monitoring system to scientists
environmentalists entrepreneurs and
individuals in a region that has little
data Gathering capacity of its own here
you have it basically literally
available at your fingertips
so that as a researcher as a developer
as a business developer for that matter
you can see the trends and you can build
your knowledge from that
the eu's decision to share this
information with Latin America might not
just be for environmental reasons this
region is home to the world's most
strategic minerals including copper and
lithium resources that China now
dominates
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santiago